to Mark Hills and Jim Vance for the
design and Engineering of the fq render
farm management system the academy
presents a technical Achievement Award
please join me here on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
um
Jim and I were chatting earlier not just
about rendering versus simulation but um
that opening clip it's someone we
respect a great deal said in the opener
there a long time back
um nobody ever grows up with a dream to
be a render queuing engineer
well
it was back in the 90s and I was a
teenager
and a local local business near me I was
in the trash there and I found the
component parts of 50 office PCS
now I did as anyone would do I called my
mum
and she was surprisingly uh took very
little persuasion to drive down in our
family car and come and collect in some
sort of heist basically out of hours we
collected these into the back of the car
um
now a few key opponents key components
were missing from this
um but after a great deal of work and a
lot of effort and a lot of learning I
had my own supercomputer built into a
kitchen cupboard in the house
um now it did some spectacular things
when you switched it on the wall it sort
of fizzed and popped genuinely but it
wasn't just a fire hazard it was
actually capable of rendering computer
animation
um and to do that there was one missing
piece of the jigsaw that I had to write
I had to write some render queuing
software to make that happen
so when
I think without my mum doing that
things would be very different wouldn't
they and I would like to dedicate this
award to my mum and dad because they
always saw the opportunities in the kind
of crazy things that I was doing back
then and and seeing those opportunities
is where that came up at frame store
really
um Jim and I had rather ambitious plans
for what we want to do and it was our
mentors at frame store that took a
chance on those ambitious plans so
we'd like to start by thinking then
so yes um we'd like to thank all those
at frame store
um for your support and encouragement
without which we wouldn't be here today
um we want to make special mention of
all those who have passed through the
systems development team over the years
the software we developed together for
Film Production from fq onwards I think
marked a special time in frame store's
history
um we want to single out Rob Dooley
for his dedicated maintenance and
contributions to fq
on a more personal note I'd like to
thank my wife Mona for her enduring
support and she would be here with me
today if it wasn't for the more
important task of looking after our son
back at home whilst I'm gallivanting
around Hollywood
um we want to thank the academy not only
of course for this award but for what it
represents uh the recognition of the
impact of the wider infrastructure
category
um on the development of the effects
shots
this we hope will serve as uh
inspiration and encouragement for future
generations to innovate in the same
space pushing forward their Creative
Solutions
and finally I'd like to thank you all as
well for a warm welcome you've made a
couple of Brits feel right at home with
this familiar weather
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you